we have an update this morning in our  ongoing CBS News investigation a  potential carbon monoxide leaks in some  Ford Explorer models to Washington State  Troopers have each filed one million  dollar lawsuits against the State Patrol  they alleged the department knowingly  exposed them to carbon monoxide and  police versions of the vehicle both  troopers were hospitalized with elevated  levels of carbon monoxide in their blood  the lawsuits allege the department knew  about possible dangers but did not do  enough to warn employees Ford says the  leaks are the result of third-party  alterations to the Explorers but a  letter from the state's Department of  Labor says the exhaust issues are  related to the vehicles themselves the  possible leaks affect explorers from the  model years 2011 through 2017 both the  Washington State Patrol and Ford said in  statements that safety is one of their  top priorities